[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we have a new release date for the Loki
season 2 premiere and we have a new
teaser for it we're also going to be
going over some huge plot details that
we have recently learned about the Loki
series concerning what Loki Mobius and
OB are trying to do with the time Loom
so if you are curious as to what exactly
is happening in the trailers with this
particular scene where Mobius is wearing
an astronaut suit going out to the time
Loom we'll shed some light on what
exactly is happening in this video now
as far as the new Loki release date is
concerned it is good news not bad news I
know there have been a lot of Marvel
delays recently and just delays in the
industry in general due to the writer
strikes and the actor strikes and
everything going on but the premiere has
actually been moved up by a day instead
of releasing on October 6th Marvel
Studios is releasing Loki season 2 on
October 5th at 6:00 p.m. now this could
be huge this could indicate a huge
change for Disney plus and Marvel
Studios we've talked about this briefly
before but this could mean that every
episode is now going to be coming out at
6:00 p.m. Pacific time and that would be
900 p.m. eastern time that that's what's
been happening wow this is fantastic
news because now fans on the East Coast
don't have to wait till 3:00 a.m. to
watch it and fans on the west coast
don't have to wait till 12:00 a.m. and
the reason we believe that every episode
is going to Premiere at 6:00 p.m. is
because this is exactly what they're
doing right now for Ahsoka every Tuesday
each episode releases at 6:00 p.m.
Pacific time and great news for those
who used to attend we'll be bringing
back the watch parties since it's at a
good time now we'll start our watch
parties up again and we can do watch
parties together now as I mentioned we
did get a new teaser for Loki season 2
today it's kind of a behind the scenes
but they do actually give us a lot of
new footage and a lot of new details
about what exactly Loki is trying to do
in Loki season 2 now to start off Marvel
Studios right off the bat with this new
teaser confirm something huge for those
of you who were wondering and were kind
of concerned about this Kevin rri a
Marvel Studios executive producer for
Loki season 2 States that R Loki will be
with r Mobius and they will be dealing
with the consequences of Loki season 1
now I've seen a lot in the comments and
on Twitter that people were kind of
disappointed and concerned that Loki
kind of goes back in time at the end of
Loki season 1 and now in Loki season 2
he isn't dealing with the same Mobius
that he has the history of season 1 with
a lot of people were worried that they
were going to have to start that
relationship over again but that is not
the case and Marvel Studios confirmed it
right here and we also do kind of know
how Loki episode 1 starts off and ends
yes Loki does go back in time and yes
the TVA does exist outside of space and
time however from what we've been told
time still moves through the people in
the TVA so Loki gets time displaced at
the end of Loki season 1 and in the
beginning of Loki season 2 he starts
time slipping which isn't supposed to be
possible because again the TVA exists
outside of space and time however
ultimately we know that OB who is one of
the first TVA people who worked with
Kang the Conqueror slhe who remains he
literally helped him create the TVA and
the sacred timeline we've actually seen
footage of that in other trailers as
well but ultimately OB creates a device
that allows Loki to kind of control time
just like the TVA does so ultimately
Loki will go back to the time where he
came from he'll go back to the same
timeline from Loki season 1 where he
revealed to Mobius and Hunter B15 and
everybody else that the TVA was not what
they think that the timekeepers weren't
real and they were real people before
they weren't created by the TVA but they
were actually taken by the TVA and now
Loki will be back in that same time and
he will tell them about he who remains
and then they'll set off on their
journey to find Victor timley for a very
very specific reason and it's actually
very cool and very clever and it's not
what you think we'll deep dive into that
in just a bit but first big thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you may know that I personally
use hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than 7 days for Quality you
can taste if you are trying to impress
your friends this summer by doing some
cooking for them hellofresh makes it
super simple they give you all of the
ingredients and tell you exactly how to
make each meal and the best part is
right now if you go to hellofresh.com
sl50 Cosmic you can use use code 50
Cosmic for 50% off plus free shipping
that's hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off your order and free shipping now we
know that Loki and Mobius are going to
run into Victor timely this was the post
credit scene for Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and we've also seen him
many times now in the trailers and the
TV spots for it and a lot of people
think that they are going to stop a
earlier version of he who remains so he
doesn't become he who remains but it
seems like that is not the case we've
seen in the trailers this new team Loki
Mobius Sylvie OB Hunter B15 Etc we've
seen them staring at the sacred timeline
we've seen them staring at the time Loom
and we've also heard Sylvie tell Loki
that they're playing gods and Loki says
we are Gods but the reason Sylvia is
telling Loki this is because of what
happened at the end of Loki season 1 the
option of Loki and Sylvie being in
charge of the TVA determining which
timeline lives and which doesn't that is
essentially them playing Gods however
Loki now knows more about what he who
remains in the variants are up to and he
knows that maintaining that sacred
timeline is how to keep Kang and his
variants away so Loki and them are
trying to figure out a way to actually
control the sacred timeline and continue
creating the future however and this is
the big part what we've heard is that
Loki and Mobius and OB they can't
actually access the sacred timeline
because essentially it has a password
essentially nobody but Kang the
Conqueror can access it or a variant
because they have the same DNA so it
appears that Loki and Mobius might not
be seeking a variant of he who remains
because they are trying to stop he who
remains but they actually need him to
unlock the sacred timeline and based off
of the footage that we have seen in some
of these trailers it does look like
Victor timley does indeed go back to the
TVA and is inspecting the sacred
timeline and a model of what seems to be
the bridge that goes out to the sacred
timeline so it seems like they do
eventually get him back to the TVA which
he probably hasn't invented yet at that
point in time so they're trying to kind
of align themselves with a king who
hasn't essentially become king yet
however if they are taking directly from
the story of the comics this Victor
timely Kang variant is not going to be
so good in the comics Kang whose real
name is Nathaniel Richards is from way
in the future he discovers a time travel
device and goes back into ancient Egypt
times he rules as the pharoh ramut until
he is defeated by The Fantastic Four
from there he gets a little time
displaced he runs into Dr Doom some
other stuff happens until he eventually
goes back in time to Earth and takes on
the guys of Victor timley so if they are
taking from that story this Victor
timley could have already been the king
who has conquered ancient Egypt and if
he is indeed evil which we know the
majority of the king variants are and if
he is evil he might take this
opportunity to actually try and cease
control over the TVA or its technology
and we could actually see a stronger
Kang created here but we do know that
that is why Loki and Mobius are seeking
Victor timely because they need a Kang
variant to be able to access the sacred
timeline now there's actually another
really big point of the teaser that we
saw this morning and something that I
really really love is that they State
Loki is going to be exploring what they
call his heroic ISM we hear Sylvia ask
Loki what is it you really want and he
replies with I want to save my friends
and then Tom Heston behind the scenes
says that realizes that those
connections are all that matters in the
end meaning the connections with his
friends with the people he cares about
with the people that he loves so we're
seeing a very evolved Loki here a Loki
that is no longer really the villain but
is actually a hero and he's not only
trying to save his friends in Loki
season 2 but he's also essentially
trying to save the entire universe and
possibly the entire Multiverse so we are
seeing the rise of an epic hero here and
I think Loki is going to play a really
huge part part in Avengers Secret Wars
and I personally am super excited and
can't wait to see Loki season 2 and what
happens in King Dynasty and Secret Wars
let us know how excited you are in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can always find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
wolf